immer wieder werden falsche
wissenschaftliche studien
veröffentlicht die haben wir ja über
die falsche studie zum durch ihn
verursachten autismus berichtet und das
ist kein einzelfall es versuchen immer
wieder hochstapler lügner und
größenwahnsinnige durch fallstudien
aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen
mit zum teil tödlichen folgen wie bei
der impfstudie jetzt schlägt der
medizin-nobelpreisträger randy jackman
alarm den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
die folgen der im fachmagazin the lancet
veröffentlichten und inzwischen
zurückgezogenen studie zum durch ihn
verursachten autismus sind fatal
zahlreiche eltern vergehen sich an ihren
kindern und kindern den richtigen ist
werden können indem sie die impfung
verweigert die folgen sind fatal
die impfrate ist dadurch weltweit
deutlich gesunken und es gibt in folge
tote frühgeburten oder schweren
spätfolgen am schlimmsten betroffen
sind kleine babys die noch nicht geimpft
werden können stecken sie sich bei
nicht geimpften kindern oder erwachsenen
ist das risiko an einer tödlichen
gehirnentzündung zu erkranken extrem
hoch viel höher als bisher gedacht gott
sei dank geht die impfquote wieder nach
oben und bei einer info davon immerhin
inzwischen wieder fast 95 stellen eltern
fest dass offensichtlich nicht
massenhaft autismus auf segways studie
wurde zurückgezogen er darf nicht mehr
als arzt arbeiten und trotzdem glauben
ihm noch immer menschen immer wieder
gibt es masern epidemie in italien gibt
es deshalb jetzt seit mai eine
impfpflicht nicht geimpfte kinder
bekommen keinen kita platz und es drohen
empfindliche strafen 2016 hatten sich
masern fälle auf und 2005 400 fälle
fast verdreifacht eigentlich wollte die
gesundheitsbehörde die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die masern
wie die pocken schon längst ausgerottet
haben dann werden nämlich gar keine
impfungen mehr nötig wakefield falsche
studie hatte so und hat sie leider immer
noch dramatische folgen dabei hätte das
verhindert werden können wenn die
checks man jetzt in einem interview im
spiegel kritisiert also in spiegel
online
schuld seien die fachzeitschriften bei
wall and set wurde die welt feldstudie
wie alle veröffentlichungen vorher von
kolleginnen und kollegen in peru
verfahren überprüft laut jackman
hatten es alle gutachter kritisiert und
auch die redakteure fanden die studie
mangelhaft lediglich die chefetage
wollte die veröffentlichung und setzte
sie durchaus sensationsgier verlegern
vom fachmagazin geht es darum studien zu
veröffentlichen die möglichst oft
zitiert werden
das bestimmt den sogenannten impact
factor bei dieser studie waren sie sich
sicher dass das passieren würde und sie
hatten recht doch sie waren einem
betrüger aufgesessen noch schlimmer ist
es laut jackman im bereich biomedizin
jackman berichtet vom pharmakonzern
amgen deren wissenschaftler einen
großteil der externen studie nicht
reproduzieren konnten in einem fall
fragten sie den autor einer studie deren
versuchen sie 50 mal versucht hatten zu
reproduzieren was nicht gelang der
forscher erklärte daraufhin dass er
erst sechs mal probiert hätte und es
einmal geklappt hätte deshalb habe er
die studie publiziert und genau das ist
betrug einmal reicht nicht es kann
einfach zufall sein
und das ist quasi noch ein harmloser
einzelfall es gibt komplett erfundene
studien gefälschte
untersuchungsergebnisse und so weiter
und so fort jackman fordert jetzt
fachmagazine auf anders bewertet zu
werden oder anders zu beurteilen und die
häufigkeit der zitat also den impact
factor anders zu bewerten im moment
korreliert nämlich die häufigkeit der
zitate der veröffentlichten studien mit
der häufigkeit der zurückgezogenes
studien umso mehr die studien in einer
fachzeitschrift zitiert werden desto
häufiger müssen dort auch studien
zurückgezogen werden plötzlich wurde
der gesamte wissenschaftsbetrieb
korrumpiert und in schieflage gebracht
wissenschaftler werden zum betrug quasi
verführt oder zumindest zu
übertreibungen jackman will das ändern
bei der fachzeitschrift nature sieht er
eine positive entwicklung der intec
fekter wird nicht mehr so in den
vordergrund gestellt und auch sehr
selbst publiziert chefredakteur mit ihm
live einfacher magazin dass keine
gewinne erwirtschaften will
und dementsprechend etwas andere
überschriften hat ein beispiel auf
deutsch zum beispiel die mäßige nimmt
nucleotide vielfalt im atlantischen
hering ist mit einer niedrigen
mutationsrate verbunden naja vielleicht
könnte es doch etwas spannender sein
wohin die reise geht mehr gefälschte
studien oder weniger ich halte euch hier
bei pixum auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein video verpassen wollt dann durch
mir hier ein abo aufs auge
vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke und hier geht es weiter
wenn diese über zehn fakten von denen
wir wissen also von denen wir eigentlich
nichts wissen falsche fakten zehn dinge
in dem glauben zu wissen heißt das
video
wenn es euch interessiert einfach
draufklicken ansonsten bis dann bleibt